still looks good okay this is three
weeks expired so yeah it's kind of
already fermented milk so it's always
been expired donate that yogurt
generally has a 10 to 21 days shelf-life
when stored properly in the refrigerator
below 40 degrees Fahrenheit thanks Carl
oh yeah my family's been blown forever
all the way back since the dinosaurs
actually it was only eleven thousand
years ago that blond hair developed to
allow more vitamin D as an evolutionary
response to the sunlight oh and
dinosaurs they don't have hair I'm a
huge fan what was like being the first
Wonder Woman in a feature film oh
actually the first person to play Wonder
Woman in the movie was Cobie Smulders in
this 2014 lego movie
oh but ii like being the second Wonder
Woman in a feature film awesome you know
what I will have a coconut watch a
coconuts my favorite kind of that
actually if the fibrous one see the
droop from the Indian Indonesian region
they spread itself by floating around
the world riding ocean currents actually
I just looked that up and it turns out
the origin of the plant is undetermined
I got a good day just thought you'd like
to know
you know you can actually animate this a
lot easier and after-effects with a few
keyframes yeah I know it's a lie
[Music]